à paris dans un climat extrêmement tendu
les défenseurs du droit à l'avortement
se sont opposés aux militants d'un
colloque international qui réunissait
les mouvements très actif pour la
défense de la vie les forces de police
ont dû barrer l'accès au palais de la
mutualité elizabeth est gelé laetitia
legembre la vedette aujourd'hui c'était
lui le docteur xavier dor leaders des
mouvements anti avortement le but de
voir comment chaque le monde après avoir
dédicacé sa dernière oeuvre
il est ovationné par des centaines de
militants venus du monde entier
sympathisants de mouvements d'extrême
droite et catholique convaincu ils sont
là pour remobiliser les troupes
au même moment deux contre-manifestation
lune juste devant la mutualité où se
tient le colloque
elle rassemble entre autres féministes
et anarchie l'autre à la sorbonne réuni
défenseurs des droits de l'homme et
personnalités du monde médical et
politique
notre corps nous appartient le corps des
femmes appartient d'abord aux fins avant
qu'ils appartiennent à quiconque a des
églises à des partis politiques ou à des
factions social voire professionnelle
béatrice geindre elle mère de quatre
enfants ne partage pas cet avis il est
rare qu'elles ressentent dans la rue
mais l'avortement elle a toujours été
contre pour elle avorté s'est tué canard
c'est quand même un sujet très très
grave à notre époque parce que c'est une
génération qui disparaît t'as qu'à un
quart des enfants qui disparaît comme ça
par l'avortement peut pas être
indifférent voilà béatrice à ses
convictions mais n'approuve pas les
actions des commandos elle est donc
minoritaire car les associations anti
ivg reprennent du poil de la bête
je pense que les autorités de ce pays et
d'autres pays doivent faire attention
parce que de moins en moins nous
supporterons con ce crime abominable de
moins en moins xavier dor et épaulé par
le pape qui l'a reçue récemment et par
les américains
aujourd'hui son action vise à obtenir le
soutien de l'opinion publique